she was hit down hard feel alright him
what would I be feeling already looking
at a dead child what copper is the term
was more of a derogatory term back in
the day back in the 1860s for a
policeman and the copper comes from the
badge being made out of copper Lewis was
good to be on the road to a little ah
the show begins after Kevin corporates
come back from the Civil War he's been
fighting for the north and whilst he's
there he finds out that his wife is
disappeared of his daughters have been
killed so he eventually comes back he's
been through a hell of a lot of turmoil
but the show picks up while he's
searching for any any nugget of
information that he can and he'll do
anything to get it he's got a job to
fulfill as a detective as policeman but
as soon as anything brings him back is
into remembering why he's actually what
his purpose is then he a completely
drops everything and there won't be
anyone to get what he wants
I don't think Corcoran by any means will
be everyone's favorite I think there's
certain people like Dylan Taylor who I
think is an amazing actor he plays um
Andrew O'Brien and he's cut he was part
of the threesome that make that makes
the UH detective force with Kevin Ryan
who plays Francis Maguire and every
little character has got a huge amount
of stories tied to it and they all have
flaws
they all act
and they all have a twist is that I
don't think anyone really expects you
get insight into these different worlds
and these different times which you
would not have the energy to if you did
something else but it's really
fascinating that period of American
history and you get a sense that
everything so quick and sharp and fast I
find that with American history that
it's just so immediate and things tumble
out of control very quickly in American
history and you get a real sense of that
in the show the show is obviously
setting five points but through
corporals eyes you get a picture of the
whole of the city people have been
forced and jigsaw together forced to
co-exist and it it makes the great
viewing in just the sense that you
always think that something could happen
something could potentially explode and
burst at any moment and that tension
rides throughout the whole story it's
incredibly vibrant and
I saw on the sense that you I think you
can smell the show when you watch it
what I've seen you really get a sense of
how it stank anything